[Music]  resident evil 7 is scheduled for release  late January 2017 to commemorate this  momentous occasion we are dedicating the  entire month to resident evil themed  content we'll look back at the story and  we'll break down all the information we  think you should know before you play  the game on January 24th expect content  from a centered around all the heroes  the villains the virus strains and the  history of Resident Evil please press  subscribe so you don't miss an update  and it's free remember don't know your  tyrants from your hunters are your ADA  from your Claire or maybe you just need  a jill sandwich hurry this way that was  too close you were almost a Jill  sandwich come join us all month here on  playstation grenade